[Music]
you know I had some when I was a kid I
had some kind of issues I don't know
exactly what they were but uh-huh I was
in some at the tu-134 interchange it was
like a hospital there you know my mom
had me in there doing intensive therapy
when you were a kid yeah I was like Dix
Alexia right left confusion balance
issues different language difficulties
they couldn't figure out what it was
that were ya know I had some tag I don't
know what the exact diagnosis was uh-huh
but my brain had to learn new ways of
doing certain things Wow well and I
still like you know do certain letters
backward you know I mean they're the
right way it's just I don't I do
whatever way right but not like textbook
dyslexic no yeah but you must have been
a good student dude you went to Harvard
so I figured it out somehow yeah yeah I
know I did but I mostly read and just
like was kind of learned on my own
uh-huh could kick a football really far
I think I soccer was my passion and then
crossover and a football got recruited
in the different colleges oh wow so gene
you play football at Harvard yeah for
two years you did yeah what you're you
were the kicker yeah I kicked from nine
well 91 and 92 and then but I got a
little bored because haha soccer was my
life right
my friends were playing rugby and having
a lot more fun it was wasn't
n-c-double-a yeah and it just kind of
blended more of my skill set plus there
was no drug testing for which was the
important benchmark matically you know I
have a hard time visualizing you in a
football uniform though I wouldn't know
that yeah Wow
yeah I know it was yeah and you know and
it just got less fun you know like just
before our practices day in day I hear
you brother
yeah it's work yeah yeah and I just
wanted to make sure I was playing a
sport I was a lot more passionate about
uh-huh I mean I enjoyed I played tight
end in high school but I wasn't good
enough to play at that level your big
dude right like what are you like six
six or something success Wow yeah you're
a tall to you
where'd you go to high school Hoover hi
I'm Glenn oh right
so LA native thanks for coming back up
yeah and Sanitas to talk to me been
looking forward to this for a long time
lots of points of interest and stuff we
can explore I guess the first thing I
want to know as somebody who is at the
vanguard like the activist Vanguard of
everything sustainable regenerative
eco-friendly you know somebody who
really lives in this space like what's
the top of mind for you right now what
do you have you what do you like
knee-deep in at the moment that's most
interesting right on well we were
launching with partners including
Patagonia the clothing company and then
leading animal welfare org
like compassion well farming leading
Fair Labor orgs like federal project and
leading soil health organizations like
Rodale and Demeter Demeter holds the bow
dynamic standard and Rodale the heart of
the organic farming movement a single
standard called regenerative organic
that basically brings together the best
of the soil health animal welfare and
fair labor into a single standard a
single consumer-facing
certification standard so that when you
purchase food or clothes or so you can
know that not only was it grown in a way
that respects the soil but also all the
people in the farmers and the workers
involved with treated fairly and any
animals or livestock involved where it
was a pasture based system no confined
like the Hika like a whole other level
of animal welfare criteria than the
current organic standard right like this
high watermark that takes into
consideration labor conditions the way
the soil is treated and and on top of
that how the long the long-term
sustainability prospects of the manner
in which the product whether it be food
or soap or what-have-you is harvested
yeah totally and this you know we feel
like we're like one third of their
surface is basically been terraformed
under industrial agricultural
mismanagement
we were wrecking the planet in a lot of
different ways but agriculture is one of
our main ways of doing it and but if we
do it in a in a correct way with
regenerative organic principles if you
look at a wild ecosystem you have known
no synthetic chemical inputs no
pesticides and fertilizers there's a
sustainable balance of animal and plant
life and it's all integrated and our
farming systems need to replicate a
natural echo system and not be dependent
on synthetic chemical inputs right yeah
yeah I mean soil health is is is really
you know the essential ingredient and
you know the the long-term viability of
our species and and many animal species
it's a subject that's come up on this
podcast many times most recently with
dr. or Zack Bush you know do you know
Zack at all maybe if you guys don't you
definitely show know each other cuz
you're on the same wavelength year but I
think it would be informative for people
that that perhaps you know aren't as
steeped in this as you are to understand
the difference between organic and
regenerative and on top of that kind of
what's like canvas what's going on in
this world of labeling that I think it's
creating as much confusion that is
clarity right on well I mean so what's
the the default right now conventional
industrial agriculture is it's it's
basically chemical agriculture Jenna
mostly genetically engineered commodity
crops like soy and corn that are grown
for our feed like one over one half of
American agriculture now is devoted to
feed crops that are inefficiently
converted in animal animal energy
carbohydrates and protein in these
animals are in confined animal factory
k5k foes and so it's just you know it's
it's a horrendous situation from an
animal welfare perspective and then but
from an environmental perspective taking
the the animals off the land and putting
them in boxes and then growing the feed
crops where they were
so that their fertility is not
integrated into the cropping cycle there
instead of these huge manure lagoons
that are spewing methane into the air
where we're instead bringing these crops
to harvest with with more and more
synthetic nitrogen and other fertilizers
and synthetic nitrogen is made in the
haber-bosch process it's one of the most
energy intensive reactions that we do on
the planet it consumes one to three
percent of the world's energy to make
synthetic nitrogen and then it destroys
the soil biota the natural life in soil
so it was a living organism it's a
living ecosystem and we're basically
systematically destroying the life in
that soil and bringing our crops to
harvest as more and more chemical inputs
and treating soil like dead dirt like an
inert medium instead of the life-giving
resource that it is and so so you know
and we have just way too much livestock
like the populations totally
unsustainable so so organic is like the
neck is you know is a good step a key
step which is basically removes chemical
inputs you can't use chemical
fertilizers or chemical pesticides when
you grow crops but in and of itself it
doesn't have necessarily prescribe a
high level way of managing your farm it
just says what you can't do it doesn't
say what you should do and regenerative
is kind of what you should be doing and
regenerative is a set of principles
where you farm in nature's image and if
you in a natural ecosystem you never see
bare ground or that's um you know that's
maybe there's a fire some and then
quickly it's covered over yeah and when
you see our farmlands it's like bare and
open to erosion and topsoil loss I mean
that's that's ridiculous and we need to
have roots in the ground all the time so
you're always having you're always
putting in your next crop or a cover
crop as soon as you harvest so you keep
roots in the ground you keep a diverse
crop rotation right with dis interrupts
pest cycles naturally
and then you minimize the the chemical
inputs and it's essentially the Joel
Salatin Polyface farms model is that
accurate uh yeah it's in in in large
extent I mean I would my one critique of
polyphase I mean obviously it's outside
of the factory farm model and that's
crucial and obviously having animals be
on grass especially ruminants is is
awesome
but the feed like each take took there's
a difference between ruminants which is
your your cattle ride a large herbivores
large herbivores so they can actually
get their energy from grass but chickens
and pigs mano gastrics like ourselves
they can supplement off pasture I mean
they'll eat some bugs and some seeds but
they're the lion's share of their diets
so coming from grain that's being bought
in from elsewhere and so joel is as of
my current understanding is still not
like that grain like how that grain is
grown it's going to kind of make or
break the kind of the the impact of how
the earth is being treated at the amount
of carbon that's been sequestered
sequestered one way to look at it is if
we wave a magic wand and get all of our
chickens and pigs out of their cages and
back on the land and a kind of Polyface
style farm which is obviously great from
an animal welfare perspective to the
extent that they're treated well and
that freedom of movement and ideally
their end is humane and quick that even
if we wave a magic wand if we don't
change their feed like you're still for
a monogastric you've still got to feed
the same amount of corn and soy as you
would in a cage right is on a path
you're gonna have to grow that somewhere
and you have to grow it and so how
that's grown is still matter right
crucially and it's kind of a hole in the
Allan savory argument right as well
because isn't that sort of part of the
same thing yeah so like one of our
critiques of the savory certification is
on the ruminant side it's solid that you
know insofar as they're emphasizing
cattle should be on grass it should be
eating only grass on
given land mm-hmm but their
certification has a hole in insofar as
bought in feed when you do a get bought
in you know coroners soy for your
monogastric but then even for ruminants
they'll buy and hay chopped hay mm-hmm
and cut hay and a lot of times that hay
is grown like all feed crops with a
whole bunch of synthetic fertility and
pesticides so like even if you're
regenerating the land where your
livestock are roaming like what about
the land that's growing on your feet
ROPS and if you're not taking
responsibility for that then you're not
exactly yeah yeah look you're a longtime
vegan dude like what since like 96 or
something like that yeah all right you
know I've been vegan for 15 years yeah I
would I would prefer to you know have a
vegan utopia where we all wake up and
realize that we don't need to be eating
these animals at all that it's
incredibly inefficient yeah and all that
it just you know we all we all you know
have this you know spiritual epiphany
and we transcend to the next plane of
consciousness overnight we're on yeah
I'm you know yeah I'm I'm working hard
towards that vision as well but that's
not happening tomorrow and given the
fact that it's not a plausible reality
in the immediate future we do have to
consider you know better solutions for
the omnivorous planet that we live on
and that involves taking into
consideration you know how we're raising
these room and it's is there a better
way for the meeting population well we
continue to eat meat and the demand for
me continues to rise so one of the big
questions I have for you is you know
given Malad you for pursuing this
regenerative organic certification I
think it's super important but is this
if we were to all adhere to this
standard we couldn't we don't have
enough land or resources to feed the
demand for meat as a current little kids
right like if all farms certain you know
adhere to this standard overnight all of
a sudden we could be a lawless lot
we can't we can't do it no I mean that's
it I mean this method of farming depends
on a much lower population right ten
percent of the population livestock out
of their cages integrated back into the
land and and you know and to be clear
animals are not essential to regenerate
organic system you know we can't have a
totally vegan method of farming but
insofar as livestock are involved then
yeah they need to be integrated in a
pasture based way and their population
needs to be dramatically reduced so
regardless of whether we choose the meat
or not we have to be much less of it and
much better if we want to transition our
agriculture to a truly relative basis
and and that becomes problematic when we
see the rise of the middle class in
places like China and India where yeah
demand for me know skyrocketing right
now yeah that paints a grimmer picture
well ends with the plausibility of this
oh absolutely and actually so another
big piece of our advocacy is on meat
reduction and vegan advocacy and we were
big supporters of good food institute
Mayo menus on that show yes is rocking
and obviously bringing in the next-level
meat substitutes and dairy substitutes
are key
we just obviously need to be reducing
our meat consumption and in the
developed world but then as you say in
the developing world like this is not we
you know we need to skip what we did
like we need to it's kind of like
hopefully what they're doing with like
going from no phones this you know 4G
cellular like if we keeping the stepping
though you know skipping some coal may
be going straight to Seoul you know we
can skip what we did here with
agriculture yeah you know or at least
well you know cuz like India right like
they have I mean most our population was
and maybe still is vegetarian although
now that's starting a shift but they
still have the cultural memory of the
ethics of it so if you can bring in like
okay so now maybe they develop a taste
for you know lamb or or whatever it is
that is interfering
kind of their traditional more is like
if you can bring in like a you know like
a clean meat or something that
approximates that taste and texture and
feel on price and everything else Bruce
says you know then you know maybe we can
avoid right a disaster you don't have to
overcome a lifetime of a lifetime habit
of eating meat in a different way
yeah right I mean the cultural memories
there and you know hopefully yeah it's
gonna be interesting because it's
happening at some point yeah it's you
know I was on a panel with Fallon with
the CEO of Memphis meats uh-huh I think
I've alladhi yeah it was like a few
years ago and I think he had like the
meatballs were like 10 grand a pop yeah
at that point but I think they're down
to a grand and they're about to be 10
bucks and you know I'm very soon they're
gonna be you know ten cents yeah that'll
be a whole defeat chip saying because I
keep bugging him to come on the podcast
it's like I'm not ready yet we're still
working we still got a long way to go
but it seems like it's advancing pretty
quickly I mean it really is just a
matter of time before they hit some
inflection point and the price will will
you know be able to comport with
consumer demand for it and we're gonna
see some big changes yeah I think I
think you know increasing the
availability of tasty plant-based
options is you know key part of the
equation and then the consciousness of
you know why we should be thinking about
you know what we're eating and do we
really need to be killing an animal to
sustain ourselves or do we can we not do
that and if we choose to do that let's
like really take responsibility right
for that and make sure that animal lived
a life that you know wasn't you know
going to hell and back and you know and
that's a big other part of our advocacy
is integration of cannabis and
psychedelic allies to help us wake up
some of these dimensions of our
collective planetary being and so we're
hopeful that you know we're going to be
bringing these these allies into the
culture in a significant way and in the
coming years and as as the sustainable
you know plant-based options or more
you know yeah and the consciousness the
vegan movement everything else is really
hitting its stride so you are your
grandfather's grandson yeah you are you
know I want to get into it I want to get
into the consciousness stuff because
this this is like amazing to me and
super trippy and awesome because you're
carrying a certain vibration that really
is the legacy of your grandfather and
it's it's fascinating to see how you've
taken that mantle in a very natural way
and not only you know gracefully assured
it into the business that you're running
with your brother but but also you know
in this very activist way in this very
conscious capitalist way that has made
not only a social impact but also
environmental and economic impact
because you've grown this company from
you know what was it like four million
in revenue in 98 so like a hundred and
eleven last year or something like that
right 122 yeah it's crazy man I mean
that is quite something
but let's track it back to your
grandfather because this guy was like
off-the-charts like a rock star in terms
of like what he was putting out into the
universe at that time yeah yeah so we're
incredibly fortunate that our founder of
my granddad dr. Bronner he was an
amazing individual he himself was a
third generation master so maker from a
gym german-jewish
so making family he was so by the time
he came of age in the 20s like his dad
and two uncles were running the family
enterprise we had three factories and we
were supplying most of the liquid soap
the public washrooms and in Germany he
was clashing with his dad and uncles in
a more of a generational way they were
pretty like you know they didn't want to
be mixing politics and so but my grand I
was pretty intense
back then he was scientist and and just
what do you think sorry I'm gonna
interrupt you a couple times what what
what was it about like what made him
that way what happened in his childhood
that made him this like spiritual
warrior from a young
yeah I don't you know my second cousin
like Mike my granddad's cousin said to
me once it's got Henry up sign says that
you know what there was always one in a
generation that was kind of out there
uh-huh
like in the holla brownish like em you
know and my grandma got that gene that's
how he just kind of said it I definitely
got the gene my generation of it and
yeah you know he was just kind of born
different I know he oh he got he
remember my great-aunt saying yeah that
poor emo you know is that beat him a lot
try to beat that craziness out of them
uh-huh you know and since so he came to
this stage when he was 21 I would just
kind of do his own thing and get you
know kind of leave his family and forge
his own life
but it was early days of the Nazi Party
right and he sort of saw it coming and
was like I'm out of here
no he I mean it was the I mean this is
29 so I mean the eventual eventual
dimensions were not clear about what was
about to happen and he did become
increasingly desperate to get his family
out his he his two younger sisters got
out one in 36 Lottie at the age of 20
and she ended up in a kibbutz in Israel
and they and gov and then another louisa
got out in 38 right before they closed
the border and she became a professor of
German at UMass Boston but before that
developed waterproofing compounds for
the American GI paratroopers in the
Korean War but didn't get any credit
everyone's a guest in your family yeah
and yeah and so but his parents like
many of the bushwa Jews thought they're
gonna write out the madness and they're
like don't rock the boat yes yeah Hitler
will be able to forget about him you
know and but the factory was area Nuys
in 1940 and they were deported and
killed and 42 and 44 and so out of that
just and then at the same time my
granddad had married and fathered three
children in the 30s and then his wife
died I got sick and died right around
the same timeframe in the mid 40s she
was doing with immense tragedy in his
life but the way he dealt
that was he felt originally called that
in a nuclear arm the world that the next
Holocaust if we don't realize our
transcendent unity across religious and
ethnic divides that the next Holocaust
were not all die we're gonna all perish
and that's when he felt called to go
forth and spread his message of unity
what he called the moral ABC and he was
also selling this natural so I mean he
had become a consultant to the u.s. soap
industry you know pngs or the world
build factories and launch products but
his main thing was sort of giving these
sermons right did yeah was he did he
come right to La Julie I know he landed
in Chicago Milwaukee so he's in
Milwaukee and in Chicago which is kind
of a crazy place to be that was the
center anti-semitism in the States back
then that's father McLaughlin had this
radio show that was super anti-semitic
you chicago-based and not the best place
in certain respects but he he was
actually in 1947 he was actually
interned in a mental asylum against his
will
some a guy named Fred Walker had
actually crucified himself or someone
obviously helped them for dr. Bronner's
peace plan so he gotten on the
authority's radar screens and so they
basically locked him up right he got put
in an asylum for a minute there yeah and
during which we have he design like a
settling system for this factory across
the river that was spewing waste he
actually like cleaned it up for them
like while I was in there like yeah and
then and then he fled on a stewardess
attempt II he got out of there and then
he came straight there he escaped yeah
scaped and came to LA oh so that's and
then and then set up shop in Pershing
Square and was in a tenement Hotel you
know mixing up his family soaps and
sermonizing on the moral ABC and it all
all 101 laws of faith yeah it's just
kind of like does it derive from the
teachings of the Essenes yeah so he saw
himself as an Essene rabbi right
and and but but he basically drew from
all faith traditions his attitude is
that all all spiritual Giants of whether
it's God Amma or Moses or Lao Tzu or
Socrates that they all were astronomer
prophets are all inspired witnessing the
majesty that has the cosmic rhythms and
and that all of them were basically
saying the same thing that you know get
over yourselves real that we realize
you're transcendent unity were all
children of the same divine source and
that's so for him the labels were way of
showing the commonality across at
different faith traditions and that you
know that that fundamentalism was the
enemy not my religion per se right have
you ever been to Rancho La Puerta yeah
in Mexico yeah totally do you know the
story of Edmond exactly exactly yes yeah
because he sounds like a very similar
guy to your crime yeah totally amazing
dude who was like fruitarian in the
jungles and had met Deborah's family
when she she was like a child bride and
he creates this this Center it's a whole
long story of him being Jewish and not
being able to settle in America or being
able to go back to Europe and finding
this piece of land in Mexico and
becoming like the first pioneer of
wellness and and fitness in the same era
in which your grandfather was living but
he was an area exactly yeah and being
totally into the Essenes he wrote all
these super trippy books and you know it
was all about healthy lifestyle and
doing this ascetic life based on the
tradition of those Palestinian Jews I
almost went bah built myself a biogenic
dwelling and was doing the ground a
little bit I mean he yeah he's a he did
they know each other and they must have
they might yes cuz like Aldous Huxley
and people like that were going down to
Rancho La Puerta yeah time and Edmond
must it he was probably around your
grandfather's age yeah I mean absolutely
I mean I granite you know how does the
Essene book of life I mean I definitely
told mark tup and
so I'm sure there was some direct
communication and obviously on the same
wavelength and you know they were
bringing in you know meditation and
Pilates and raw foods and AHA before
anybody you know that was the first
place also where because he was Edmond
was Hungarian and a lot of
below-the-line workers in Hollywood you
know people lighting camera people like
that were Hungarian as well it was a
small community they all knew each other
so you know that part of Hollywood kind
of knew what Edmund was doing down in
Mexico and so when a starlet needed to
like lose weight or dry out or you know
some actor or whatever they would they
would they would send them down to
Rancho La Puerta and that was the first
that was the beginning of like you know
what we all know like when Hollywood
people like go to detox or whatever but
they were doing it back in like the 40s
and 50s before any of you know this
stuff that we kind of you know see
everywhere happening now ya know right
on man and and I guess I mean I actually
just got the full download there in the
last year and a half I finally went and
visited and I guess he you know he was
pretty radical you know I don't know how
you didn't quite like how the spa kind
of was gentrifying or whatever I mean
you it was like pretty you know that's
pretty acidic and wanted you know people
to be honest pretty strict rough yeah
you know yogic path and yeah I guess
clash a little bit but but Debra has
really made something wonderful happen
there and she's amazing I mean it's got
to be like 95 now or so yeah and she's
taking it you know
anyway we got off we got off track a
little bit but there's so many
similarities there I couldn't help but
like talk about that but the thing is I
mean so your grandfather he's he's
giving these sermons in Pershing Square
which for people who don't know is like
this square right in the center of like
downtown Los Angeles yeah preacher man
but then people are more interested in
the soap than what's coming out of its
mouth right so the soap becomes a V
call for him to deliver his message
right he realizes that many people are
just coming to sermons to get the soap
because he's selling on the side and not
sticking around
hear what he has to say or paying
attention so he puts would he hate what
he's saying on the labels of our soap
and the soap always has been more of the
vehicle for the label than the labels
yeah there to promote the the soap I
remember the first time that I actually
took him like I saw the soap in the
store and I took a moment to actually
read what was on it and I was like this
is [ __ ] insane like how do they even
get away with having this like on a
consumer product in a store like have
you ever actually sat and read what's on
this it's completely mind-blowing yeah
and it's almost like it just slips under
the radar like I don't know how many
people like don't even pay attention to
that but like it's super intense yeah
it's you know it's right there it's
right on the soap yeah you know I I
think like you know my granddad went he
blames on the shock treatments he
received when it was when he was in turn
against his will but he wouldn't you
went he basically lost his vision and
was completely blind by by 1970 and I
don't think he realized just how busy
the labels were getting as he was
downloading more and more of the full
truth on another he's channeling that
yeah right and so now you know so now
we've got you know 3,000 words on a
court label and in its intense as you
say but it's also like very interesting
textural kind of backdrop and when you
look at it it's got this old apothecary
feel and look and I think yeah I mean
ideally people spend timing and grok the
message but it's kind of just kind of
conveys off that you know kind of
old-time authenticity and simplicity and
yeah it has a kind of vintage vibe that
now is is like hipster modern I suppose
yeah I mean it violates every design
principle and it works has it always had
that same look and feel as it evolved at
all or you stay true to what it looked
like when he was doing it yeah well he
evolved it himself like there's a funny
quote and asked
I interviewed him like 1973 and and the
reporter is like you know hey what
happened to Freud and Jung you know and
my grand I was like yo Freud and Jung
important but no longer relevant to
uniting the great space of birth you
know so he was yeah so break down his is
a lot you know his likes I cannot
philosophy of you know unity of
consciousness for the betterment of
humanity yeah I you know I mean he who
was within an overall you know Judaic I
think context but you know he saw that
the creator and creation were one we're
all one we're at inner essence one with
one another and our separateness is
illusory and and yeah so and he just
advocated a simple living close to the
earth he conducted most of his business
on the sundeck on a leopard print speedo
uh-huh and you know it's like a movie
yeah duh he's amazing you know just
really liberated cat and but really
intense you know right yeah yeah he was
kind of on the coming from the
mountaintop and at the time I mean we
can look back on it now and laud him and
see him as this visionary but what how
has he received you know in you know
when he was around yeah well I mean I
think the rise of the counterculture
really resonated on it was like perfect
timing I mean here's this guy you know
talking about you know peace and love
and living in harmony with the earth
with the soap that's concentrated
versatile you can wash your your hair
your dog the dishes by the side of the
rivers like the famous eighteen uses or
whatever it is yeah you know and just
really resonate it to the time yeah
which we now have to be based and we say
brushing with Bronner's just got a lot
better yeah
actually haven't tried to brush my teeth
with like they castile so yeah it you
know it works I don't recommend you
so yeah so with that like beat culture
and then 60s counterculture he he had
his little niche within that yeah and I
think he was frustrated that his
audience wasn't you know planetary widen
and right he wanted to unite this
spaceship instantly and you know it was
I guess maybe disappointed it wasn't
happening and on the timetable that he
was hoping but you know I think we're
you know appreciating all of his you
know and incredible gifts but also so
yeah the flaws in this character and you
know my dad my granddad was not a good
dad and my granddad basically went to go
save the world and abandon his family
more or less and and was so my dad and
ons what happens with guys like this
yeah that's the other side of the whole
thing yeah you know and he had ovens of
the Holocaust behind him and you know
just like you know it's just I mean
there's just a lot of generational
tragedy coming through the generations
but my dad really compensated and made
sure that our family like families was
first and and one of nothing to do with
all one vision or religion in general
mmm-hmm he was just all about family and
community and so me and my brother and
sister you know came up in this
incredible household in Glendale
Reaganite suburban right stable stable
and just beautiful and my dad was like
the most moral guy I mean he would just
you know stand up for whoever just
volunteers time and and so we blend his
kind of focus on pragmatics what can you
do for your brother right here right now
you know with my granddad's more cosmic
yeah trio pian yeah because he set the
company up originally as like a
non-profit religious organization and we
just funnel all the profits back into
you know into causes right yeah not I
mean that there's conscious capitalism
and then there's just you know an
unsound business practice in terms of
like longevity right
yeah and IRS disagreed with his taxes is
not a religious yes soap
right yeah so so and actually my dad
stepped in one of my mom and uncle in
the late 80s to basically give our
company out of the bankruptcy my
granddad was oh crap tons of back taxes
on you know basically not having paid
them and um but you know I was
surrounded by a bunch of bad advisers as
well and so my dad and mom and uncle dad
especially really you know righted the
ship and yeah my dad had come up and was
working for a chemical specialty firm as
a head of operations in Atwater area
where I came up and developed among
other things firefighting foam for
forests and structured fires it's now
standard and modified a version for
Hollywood as a fake snow so we grew up
blasting snow foam on trees right for
alka-seltzer ooh and this is still the
same stuff that they use right did he
patent that and like it's his that's the
end yeah yeah Warner Brothers is a
master distributor but yeah so he you
know so so the firefighting foam is
owned by some Tel Aviv base chemical
conglomerate at this point so when
you're growing up in essentially the
Pasadena area Glendale like that must
have been you must have been a popular
kid like let's go over to your house and
glass flows in credible and yeah I mean
when you when you blast foam in the
world I mean it just transforms you know
we're all one on your phone uh-huh
and it just it can't be in a bad mood
yeah you know it just transfigures the
world I mean whatever's going on is over
you know it's knots foam time and and
and it's just ecstatic Liberatore space
and now Bronner's you guys have like a
truck that drives around and sprays foam
at people's private parties and stuff
yeah so kind of blending my granddad and
dad so we take dr. Bronner's soap which
is at this point made I don't know it's
the same simple recipe is for five
generations but you know now with
regenerative organic we are olive oils
coming from Palestine and Israel
all of our coconut oil is coming from
Sri Lanka out of a tsunami relief
project and palm oil in this super
sustainable way out of Ghana in the
smallholder projects but we run that
through the compressed air foam system
and and and blast basically dr.
Bronner's so so we're like a in a
firefighting foam form uh-huh and we
have a fire truck that in honor of my
dad my dad's paranormal is an eagle so
we have huge blazing like fire Phoenix
on the front with the Benton fire on the
fire truck and then like big Plexiglas
dealers that we like shower trailers who
best bond - for pride and do you take
that to Burning Man yeah actually the
the original foam unit was I built it so
when my dad my granddad died 97 then my
dad died 98 and I had a whole complex
journey to embrace where you know what
we're gonna get there we're gonna get
into that like Oh God
but yeah so we had to shut down my dad
started the phone business basically
focused on the soap is his overwhelming
time and like 10 years later I remember
I was just like you know pop you know
how'd you do it how'd you you know raise
a family and run a business and you know
just going through a tough time and just
remembering like wow how much fun we had
with the phone and right so I went and
built a foam unit from one of his late
designs and brought it to Burning Man on
2009 and just you know hey this will be
fun and like it's sure enough man we
were putting out blocks of people are
like what you know in life it's like we
just blast them and you know so that's
basic born at Burning Man or reborn it
but the foam kind of in many ways is
what saves the soap company it was like
that what sustained your family and
allowed you guys to allowed your dad
like some some stable income in order to
right the ship with the soap company is
that oh yeah absolutely
oh yeah no absolutely I mean saved in
more ways than one really I mean it was
my dad's independent role for my
granddad he was just kind of super
intense and overbearing and somebody you
know was away from my dad to just kind
of you oversaw the soap production for
my granddad his whole life but just had
his own
and focus in life and and then yeah and
then as far as income right I mean our
so company was in bankruptcy so
absolutely a phone business was so when
you were a kid what was your perspective
on your grandfather you know he was
intense and especially I think for his
grandkids he just thought it was extra
important for us to download the moral
ABC and so is this kind of non-stop but
was your dad like pissed off my dad
would he was protective of us you know I
think cuz like I mean it was fine it was
just you oh my god it's like you know we
must unite to spaceship earth you know
and like you know what's the thirty
nights spaceship earth you weren't even
here for your event you where you
couldn't even stick around for to raise
me yeah yeah it was a little triggering
for my dad for me it was just kind of
like you know it's kind of sailing over
my head
but you know he would say you know we
expected us to memorized the mall ABC
but luckily he was blind so we could
pick up a bottle and you know I said
what's the 13th and I like music oh very
good you know but uh yeah wasn't till
later that I really appreciated what my
grandma was all about so I gather that
you were a fairly traditional kid
growing up in playing football and
soccer yeah you weren't like the hippie
Grateful Dead kid no I mean we you know
we're mischievous but yeah I'm not yeah
it took a little while to you know
really understand that dimension of
society and business right so your
traditional you go to Harvard you study
biology you're playing sports you're
all-american kid in many ways but then
life brings you to Amsterdam and then
things begin to shift is that yeah
accurate yeah you know college was where
the shift began you know definitely you
you know like being exposed to cannabis
and psychedelics initially in within
College context and a lot of free
thinking and different ideas and you
know biology I was you know I was never
like the most academically inclined kid
and he's non-interactive large lecture
formats were like you know
what am I doing here this is wasting my
time I'll just copy the notes before the
final you know like this is an
interactive learning and and to spend a
lot of time just with friends and
especially cannabis was a big sacrament
and kind of retired from alcohol culture
and and in some ways my athletes my
athletic identity wrapped up within NCAA
football and played rugby which was a
more Club sport the way looser kind of
the black sheep of the athletic program
but a lot of fun but in some of those
early experiences well and then with
mushrooms and psychedelics in early an
early mushroom experience was um was I
just remember looking down at my arm
like you know what does it mean at a
quantum level I'm not different like my
body's not different from the world and
when I eat and I poop the world's
pouring into me and through me and I'm
just one with it and had that like my
first kind of unity experience you know
not you know in a super overwhelming way
but just like in just really starting to
realize like the limitations of the
materialistic scientific review that
would explain like human consciousness
and being this is a kind of a narrow
adaptive trait that you know in a
certain sense sure but was completely
inadequate to the level of the mystery
of our existence and so I was you know
rejecting and I had earlier rejected
Christianity I would just raise
Protestant actually my dad wanted
nothing to do with anything my mom was
Protestant and then but when I was 12 I
was like well if God loved the world so
much why descendants one of my son just
here what about the Chinese and you know
and just I'd rejected Christianity can
on its own terms but then was really
having a problem with this materialistic
kind of science worldview and so
graduated Harvard with you know the fair
amount of questioning I was still pretty
apolitical but it had started to have
some important questions and yeah and
experiences but then
Amsterdam is where the fuel right got so
what I mean what led you to Amsterdam
just a just a deepen that inkling that
was initiated at Harvard yeah and I mean
at the time I mean Canada I mean I sauce
with in cannabis experience like
something really important like that
there was you know that we were this was
a sacrament worth appreciating like I
mean I knew I had not maybe the
healthiest relationship at that point
but enough to know that what we're doing
right here is way more important than
what a lot of people are doing around us
right now and like just being with each
other and listen to music and laughing
and being awesome and and so of course
Amsterdam at the time was the mecca of
cannabis culture right and this is
before prop 215 is 95 so a lot of the
American growers and we're over in
Amsterdam and so I happen to be
intersect well I had a europass I mean
technically I was gonna go see Europe
but what got to you Amsterdam and it was
the 8th annual High Times cup cannabis
cub and no more no more train rides
you're just there yeah well I went into
the spot you know there's an incredible
squat scene there this activist artistic
squad see no hope you know so
international and interesting and I'm
just like what this is amazing I don't
I'll go somewhere else later I'm gonna
stay here and um just ended up having
some huge experiences some really
massive psychedelic experiences and was
in a squat with your multi-generational
like people coming out of the
counterculture and in particular there
was a church in Arkansas of all places
that had formed with cannabis as its
sacrament in 93 our church is called and
sure enough the feds busted it up and
church members were on the run facing
ten years to life and a couple of them
were in my squat and that was in the
context of me of these really massive
psychedelic experiences that really
exposed me to the to the fact that
somehow love and light is at the heart
of this existence is absurd and tragic
and hard as a can be that that is our
ground of being and you know meeting
these people like just really waking up
to America and that wow these beautiful
people if they step fact that foot here
are gonna be arrested and they're thrown
away and the sacrament that helps us
wake up the drug war is in an important
respect of religious war on the
sacrament of my people and so really
waking up that that to that dimension
and Sam actually also was vegetarian so
that was my first like I remember him
just I was white wide open you know and
people are coming at me and like he's
like yeah you know why you mean you know
and I just remember like just kind of
going on the cannabis meditation like
just like yeah okay I got a knife I'm in
the store I can you know kill that cow
or I can just chop down some some
lettuce and you know I think I'll just
let the cow alone and and that was it
now is it you know just like a real easy
kind of you know I mean it was you know
I'm not super easy but it was like a you
know yeah okay it's pretty clear that
and that's kind of no way like these
salads can help us when we use them
intentionally collapse distances and
barriers and so anyways was just
reorganizing my life in a huge way going
through these huge shifts mm-hmm and
waking up you know well what else is
wrong you know in the world and just
waking up to the collective disaster of
Western consumption on a planet you know
not just in terms of meat and animal
products but just in general our
rapacious rape of nature to fuel our
material economy and just a total lack
of consciousness and I mean that's quite
a spiritual Epiphany yeah and yeah I
don't have I don't have direct
experiences with with psychedelics I'm
I'm like I'm a recovering alcoholic I've
been in recovery for a long time and I
never experimented with psychedelics and
now I feel that privilege has been taken
away from me so I I won't have that
experience but I can't deny that I know
a number of people like yourself who
have had very profound experiences with
these substances yeah and and it's been
not just life-changing but like
determinative of the trajectory that you
then choose to pursue for the rest of
your life like those experiences inform
in many ways because at that time it
wasn't like you were going into the soap
business right you don't want anything
to do with that yeah in fact my relevant
occasionally there was like I don't have
to do anything or anything I can grow
plants and live you know just fight this
cause and that's what I did I came to
actual all my stuff and announced to my
parents that I'm going to get amps and
grow plants I mean everyone needs to
stand up against the Sun just you know
really just well and I'm vegan which
they were like way more upset about than
but it's amazing you like tapped you
tapped a vein that you know your
grandfather was dialed into right it's
almost like you opened yourself up to a
level of consciousness that was
vibrating you know where he happened to
be sitting and you have this like all
you know all one awareness this unity
consciousness that kind of you have come
to you and you have this sense of
connectedness that then like protracting
out into everything that you've done
sense infuses everything like
sustainability is about connectedness
it's about a holistic perspective of the
impact that we're having on the soil and
the downstream you know implications of
all of these decisions that we make it's
not just organic or vegan or non-vegan
like we have to broaden that aperture
and realize the cascading implications
of how all of these things are
interrelated in a more and a broader and
more holistic way and that sensibility
like the experience he related about you
know pooping in the world kind of going
through you is like a micro example of
macro being the sustainability
implications of how you know we raise
food to feed humans on planet earth yeah
no absolutely right in this like how
that
yeah and in taking responsibility for
your your plate as a farm is your
section of the garden now in the world
you know what does it look like and when
you're being unconscious about what
you're eating you know you're just
creating a disaster no no no just
animals being treated abysmally and
being fed crops grown in a completely
unsustainable way but when you like
workers who are being unfairly treated
yeah man it's just a totally and then
but the solutions right there too I mean
if you just are conscious about it and
like okay I want to know who's growing
my food and is it being done right and
if I'm gonna eat an animal product is it
from a pasture based system that animal
live the life worth living
you know and you know you can start to
make a shift by taking responsibility
with your food choice
yeah and embodying your grandfather's
ethos and sensibility of using Commerce
as a form of activism like soap to him
was a means of delivering a message and
you've really done the same thing but
just done it in a more fiscally
responsible way yeah absolutely I mean
it's all I mean it is it is all cycles
of energy and you know just and in our
soaps like food on a plate you know it's
all agricultural based and like us
taking responsibility for our supply
chains and making sure all the farmers
are being paid a fair price and are
growing our coconuts and olives and
totally righteous ways palm it's a real
important when you say palm oil like
alarm bells go off cuz right it's the
it's the number one offender when it
comes to rapacious you know rainforests
empty you know de-evolution yeah so you
know we also use hemp seed oil and you
know hemp has this reputation as being
like the Wonder crop that'll save
humanity and palm as the reputation is
like you know the evil most vile crop
that'll take us you know right off the
cliff edge and the reality is is
that it's the the the issue is how do we
grow our crops whether it's palm or hem
it's the method of how we do it it's not
what the crop is and palm is actually
the highest per acre yielding oil crop
and can be done in a totally
regenerative organic sustainable way
unfortunately what's happening is in
like a lot of our commodity crops are
being they're clear-cutting rainforests
and ripping up wetlands dislocating
communities eliminating orangutan
habitat in Borneo and Indonesia
especially but you know soy plantations
are ripping up the you know Amazon and
so it's just up in either case like you
know how do we grow these crops in a
regenerative way and so with palm oil
like we're like in like every company
ever where we were buying from brokers
and we had no visibility we were buying
on the commodity market it's like who's
got the cheapest coconut oil that meets
our spec you know and that's how
everyone know where it comes from no
idea right and so that's the problem you
just have this race to the bottom in the
world so we said okay we want to know
who the farming communities are and just
make sure that they're doing it
correctly and and then go to market and
partnership with them so in the case of
palm well we identified a really cool
project in Ghana where small holder
farmers not farming more than 2 to 5
acres each are growing palm and are in a
cropping with banana and Kosovo and a
kind of a rich farm echo system and
there's plenty of wild ba to it by
rivers habitat for wildlife so so yeah
so you know the palm is an especially
important one obviously given the
concern with when it's not done that way
it's generally done in the worst paws
and they're able to meet your your
demand and do it in a predictable way
yeah allows you to you know basically
run your business fluidly yeah so at
this point yes but it's been a whole
adventure getting there and we do have
some kind of next best suppliers that
are doing a really good job there's a
group Alma is a really good entity
in Brazil and they're doing a really
good job it's not smallholder but
they're doing a pretty good job as far
as when it comes to palm there's another
project in Ecuador called natural
habitats and they're doing a pretty good
job but I mean we do the best job and so
we're we're basically at this point
supplying all of our own demand right
and you're getting your olive oil from
both Palestine and Israel yeah so 90
percent from the West Bank from
Palestinian farmers in the West Bank who
are basically farming regenerative lis
by default and have been facing really
difficult circumstances bringing them
olive oil market even local markets for
a while they're just under the
occupation and so we why did a Google
search for Fairtrade olive oil and the
only thing that came up was Kanaan in
the West Bank and I was like wow okay
that's intense
good but they're beautiful beautiful
project founded by this guy
Nasser Abu Farah who was a professor of
anthropology at University of
wisconsin-madison had a coffee house
full kind of folk singing Center for the
Arts kind of vibe and took the fairtrade
idea that emerged out of coffee and
cocoa and applied at the olives to his
farmers back home and then so we
partnered with him but then to be clear
we're not being anti-israel about that
we do 10% from the Israeli side half
from a Jewish family farm that happens
to be related to us like five
generations back and then half from a
Christian Arab Israeli project in the
Nazareth region so our olive oils Muslim
Jewish Christian you know in which it
was perfectly you know it uses with your
grandfather's vision and spiritual
principles that underpin the whole
enterprise yeah it's very beautiful yeah
yeah so how do you well two things first
of all as you know as somebody for whom
sustainability is top of mind and a huge
priority I have to ask the question like
if you're importing
all of these you know products
all over the world there's a you know
there's a carbon implication to that do
you try to offset that or how do you
think about or you know manage that
aspect of the business yeah so in the
cases so we're limited to using what's
called high lauric oils and these are
shorter chain saturated fats so all fats
and oils are chemically triglycerides so
whether it's beef fat or coconut oil
it's all glycerin backbone three fatty
acids and how long those fatty acids are
and how many double bonds or you know
makes the different characteristics of
different fats and oils so in a case of
soap your your high lather good hard
water soap comes from shorter saturated
oils and that basically means coconut
and palm kernel oil those are the main
main sources so we're we need to be
involved in the tropics for those raw
materials and then olive oil obviously
we could be sourcing here from
California but you know I think you know
in the hierarchy of value we're just
super psyched by the Fairtrade project
going on in in Palestine and Israel in
the Holy Land so we're going to continue
with that but we are embarked right now
and scope three emission audit and like
basically taking responsibility for all
the emissions involved at every aspect
of our business you know all the freight
all the everything and then instead of
investing in offsets we're we're
pioneering this movement called
insetting
which in within our own supply chains
within our own agricultural supply
chains regenerative organic methods like
composting and returning biomass to the
soil you're actually consists of carbon
in the soil and in fact soil is the
largest land-based carbon sink and if we
were to adopt regenerative organic
methods at global scale we could
mitigate and bring down something like a
third of excess atmospheric carbon back
into the soil a lot of the carbon up in
atmosphere is from mismanage soils from
all the life that's been destroyed and
killed
has been oxidized the atmosphere but
when you bring that soil back to life
and are you know enriching it with
carbon rich compost and inputs you can
start to build that carbon back up bring
that life back and that carbon so we're
know we're basically in setting our
carbon through these practices in our
own agricultural supply chains that's
super cool and meanwhile like you guys
are solar-powered and yeah we're solar
and yeah and that's it I mean we need to
decarbonize our economy and go green but
you know we have this huge legacy load
of excess atmospheric carbon dioxide and
and that's where the regenerative
organic is like the soil I mean
obviously there's all these high-tech
solutions yeah taking carbon auto air
but I mean if we just farm correctly we
can put a lot of it back into the soil
well there's a lot of lip service given
to you know the idea of conscious
capitalism but this is bred into the
very DNA of everything that you guys do
and I'm wondering whether at some point
along this journey when you start to
take things like Fairtrade and making
sure that you're sourcing from these
region you know farms I would imagine
that's driving your price point up there
had to be people saying you're insane
like you're gonna go out of business if
you try to adhere to this level of
integrity
you're gonna price yourself just right
out of the market and there's no way
like if you're if you're interested in
sustainability we should make sure the
business is sustainable first mmm-hmm
absolutely I mean that you know without
generating profits and healthy margin
we're nowhere and we can't support any
of the other causes and you know and we
do cap our family salaries at five to
one and all right office how long you
been doing that since twenty years
oh no 15 years 15 years so basically the
highest paid person at the company can't
make more than five times the amount of
salary the lowest paid yeah and you know
we could see early on kind of what was
happening and you know as I felt well
within that five to one week
have a lot of fun you know and and then
just as like a good mmm just a good
cutoff right in a world of CEO you know
compensation packages that are
completely insane and out of whack
that's a refreshing breath of fresh air
yeah and and that you know you can just
do so much good with you know not that
much money if you're really focused on
deploying it correctly and know the
people you know like yeah closely
involved in the causes like we are I
mean we really care about them or not
cause marketing for us like we really
want just the world that's the
differentiator I you know I feel like
there's so many companies out there now
who know they have to play in this
sandbox a little bit especially with the
coming of age of Millennials who are
concerned about these sorts of you know
save the world type issues they want to
patronize companies that are doing good
and giving back but most the vast
majority of companies who are quote
unquote giving back are doing it in a
very perfunctory way like oh we'll give
you 1% of to this or whatever but it's
not really part of the identity or like
I said earlier like the the fabric the
DNA of the company there's a different
difference like this is what you guys do
like the company exists so that you can
support these causes I feel that's right
that's and that was when I came in and
decided that I did want to run Bronner's
and you had gone through an evolution of
like wow I finally understand my
granddad's all about we didn't get to
the part of you coming back from
Amsterdam and deciding you're gonna be a
soap dude yeah but you know you but you
kind of got it yeah you know like okay I
got to the plane over my granddad was
and totally whoa you're right on it
you're a hundred percent correct we do
live in a spiritual mystery there is
love and light at the heart of all these
faith traditions and if they don't take
themselves literally and make idols out
of their beliefs and symbols and let
them be open and fluid like yeah they're
all pointing at this kind of mystery and
and finally understood my grand I was
all about and took a little while to
fully embrace coming back to work for my
dad but became a mental health counselor
in the Boston area huh for a while and
was the paranoid schizophrenic
counseling and but in the course of this
did a lot of journaling and just
realized if a company like dr. Bronner's
were to offer me a job I go for in a
second is incredible yeah and and here
was your brother working for the company
at the time
no he in a similar way he graduated
brown and went to teach English in Japan
and he didn't so so I let my dad know
sure they have my dr. Bronner died in a
March 7th and 97 the same day our
daughter Maya was born so this is a
variant wait hold on a second yeah your
daughter was born on the same day your
grandfather yeah same same exact day
March 7th of 97 and and I was reading a
book by this guy Rudyard weird for his
last name but he's um kept playing no he
was like an astrologer kind of young an
astrologer cat and he wrote this book
called the planet or zation of
consciousness and I just remembered that
that was the book I was reading you know
and on that day on that day and you know
which was my granddad's whole was what
was going on astral on some kind of
convergence of you know celestial bodies
yeah yeah I know and for me you know I
don't yeah I don't put like literalness
ended like necessarily any given
constellation context but I think in
general as a symbolic language of the
soul and deeper currents that we live in
breathe in
I like respect didn't yeah but that was
a big huge day and shortly thereafter
let my dad know I was ready to come into
the company and then shortly after that
he was diagnosed with stage 4 lung
cancer and given six months to live but
which he the for 12 months he was he
lived to see his daughter married
my brother-in-law Michael who's now our
chief of operations
my sister Lisa's rad she's got a blog
called going room green with a brown her
mom and our dad you know just really
downloaded the ropes and you up yeah and
we were you know had to shut down his
phone company to this concentrate on the
soap but was a I then within the next
couple years convinced my brother like
hey Mike you got to come back is this
nuts and I'm not like I was he had the
same blocks I did working for my dad has
worked for with his brother and you know
I just sure I'm like I'm really better
[Music]
yeah I should've like that yeah the
all-in-one vision it's happening yeah no
he's like what no no yeah so he and he's
now we're now kind of handles the
business end of it right and you're
you're you're like you can like be the
cosmic engagement officer and you know
yeah you know we I think my brother's
say like we're 85 90 percent the same
you know the we we share a lot of the
similar passions and Balkan nations and
but yeah he's a bit more pragmatic I'm a
little more cosmic and I definitely
geared at the activist side of the
enterprise and he's really especially
focused internationally he's really
built us out internationally but he's
now president and we're 5050 in the
company go home and got just total
partners and so what's uh what's the
future man well the future for Bronner's
what's the future for what's the what's
the what what is the forecast for planet
Earth from your perspective yeah well
you know I'm optimistic that you know
that the different strategies in place
like if if we do if we dramatically
reduce the amount of meat or eating if
we shift our agriculture and one third
is your surface to a sustainable
regenerative organic
if we decarbonize the economy you know
integrate these psychedelic allies and
you know to your point like that there's
there's ways that misuses these allies
and Knowland they often are but in a
medicine practice to look at okay we've
got a meditation practice and in a
medicine practice that albert hofmann
who discovered LSD he saw LSD as an
adjunct to meditative practice and and
and the founder of AAA Bill Wilson saw
famously dabbled in LSD yeah you know as
potential ways of interrupting habitual
forms of thought and patterns of
behavior and so anyway so so I'm
optimistic with all these things well I
would just to interject I don't want to
interrupt your fluidity of thought but
what's interesting about you is that
you're somebody who's been ahead of the
curve
much like your grandfather I mean your
grandpa was way ahead of things right
yeah
you're like slightly ahead of things
because you I mean you're are you the
person who was behind the initiative at
Bronner's to be the first company to
really start working with hemp like as
it became well you kind of were doing it
before it was quoted like technically
legal right nor was lawsuit oh yeah
total valence good but like to have hemp
in your product was kind of a radical
thing yeah not that long ago yeah right
so you were kind of initiated that whole
thing and also you were talking about
like micro dosing and things like that
like before it became like a Silicon
Valley you know hipster thing to do yeah
no absolutely no lion yeah and the
grandfather's legacy forward yeah well
and that's yeah right on man I mean
that's when I came in the company was
like I'm we're gonna run this like my
granddad did this is an activist engine
to make the world better and that's what
we're mostly here to do and it's crazy
what's going on with hemp now yeah so
you know it was such a long hard slog
there for 20 years and now the tide is
finally turned and um you know back in a
day like when we first put into hemp
seed oil in our so
yeah it was a huge deal right people
thought they were gonna test positive at
work and all kinds of stuff yeah yeah
and you all they've been in a bunch of
lawsuits over similar kinds of spats
right with a USDA and yeah so so first
we went to the mat with DEA like after
Bush came in and 9/11 there was the DOJ
went nuts the power justice went knots
on medical marijuana industrial hemp and
and organs euthanasia law which is
interesting because there's much there's
a ballot measure in Oregon to legalize
medical therapy to accuse of mushrooms
and definitely sell a siphon the active
ingredient it's been found to be really
beneficial for end-of-life anxiety like
that's one of the big breakthrough areas
like just helping people reconcile to
the dying process as part of a larger
life you know mystery and and and but
anyways like the DOJ was going nuts on
all these different kind of progressive
movements and so we got a big fight to
preserve industrial hemp seed oil
imports back in 2001 which ultimately
won in 2004 and then fast forward to
today Kentucky was really the big shift
with tobacco going down the tubes and
it's been the historical hemp heartland
senator Mitch McConnell the Senate
Majority Leader has been our number one
champion in Congress for the last four
years so weird yeah and like John
Boehner it works for a cannabis company
now yeah what kind of weird bizarre
University we live in yeah things are
happening no totally and that's yeah
that's incredible so so yeah so I think
it's just so I was just in DC
celebrating our big victory you know
it's awesome but we're moving on and
like one of the what the the joke I
would never answer a journalist who
would call me twenty years ago like Oh
as in hapless talking horse for
marijuana like right you know aren't you
just open a cultural space to reform
cannabis generally and of course the
answer was always like no like we're
focused on on as I Sarah having four
seed and fiber and Omega threes lacking
in the American diet and
you know em fibers it's amazing for
textiles and clothing and and it's an
amazing sustainable crop grows like a
weed you don't need a lot of synthetic
pesticides and fertility but the joke
was like no get it right this is about
LSD you know the end game no that's what
you're angling for yeah you know just
just integration of all these allies and
the culture and to help us care about
and give a [ __ ] in the first place about
the problems and and and care enough to
engage and solve them yeah well I think
we're at an inflection point with all of
these issues you know the historical
trajectory of hemp it's so we could do a
whole podcast on that alone with
everything that William Randolph Hearst
did prevent that from you know being a
staple of American daily life because of
his investments in paper and Henry Ford
and his hemp car like there's a whole
bunch of amazing stories that come out
of that but we're kind of past that now
we've overcome that hurdle and then we
have people like Michael Pollan writing
books about psychedelic experiences we
have Johns Hopkins and various other you
know organizations pouring a lot of
money into scientific research on the
implications of whether it's micro
dosing or psilocybin or other
psychoactive compounds on everything
from depression to all manner of mental
health PTSD etc so it's very interesting
times yeah you know you forecasted a lot
of this we're now living in this we're
kind of in this in-between phase I think
but I think it's inevitable that we're
heading in the direction that you
foresee when it comes to food and
agriculture and soil I - I'm optimistic
but and I've said this before I feel
like there is an arms race afoot like we
have people like yourselves and there is
a massive grassroots movement and a
growing population of activist consumers
who are concerned about these things and
the future of the planet for ourselves
and future generations who are
patronizing companies that are trying to
do good like yours but that's butting up
against like we said earlier you know
the growing populations across the
planet not just in America and this
massive increasing demand for the
products of animal agriculture and the
rapacious you know practices that go
into producing those so who is gonna win
are we gonna be able to significantly
elevate our collective consciousness to
the point that we can combat you know
what ails us or is the dark force gonna
prevail yeah you know it's Star Wars
yeah no absolutely man and actually I
was in an ibogaine experience with a
buddy and ibogaine is has great promise
for opiate addiction in particular it's
it's a really powerful African root
princess Aikido and in a black panther
they kind of allude to allude to it a
little bit the medicine in that movie
that we hit the ancestral plane and that
it's not ayahuasca no it's an eye bogut
so i boga i bogus oh it's another reef
arguably even even more intense a plant
psychedelic ally and but it within this
vision I had like saw my grandma over
here and in like the planet Earth and
all the life artists and activists fight
in the machine and Trump and all the you
know are we gonna win and and you know
feeling like forces other dimensional
forces plugging in hope you know from
who knows and then at a certain point
golden light like breaks out on the
earth and you know it was you know and
every summer beautiful specs and
beautiful so I I will hold that energy
frequency for the future of humanity and
yeah hopefully yeah good well I think
that's a good place to close it down
dude yeah right on yeah I think so it's
awesome man thank you so much I love
that dude thank you yeah very cool
I would say I say with with a fair
amount of certitude that after listening
to this podcast when you go to the store
and you see that dr. Bronner's soap
you're gonna you're gonna look at it
differently for the rest of your life
after
in this conversation you're always gonna
think back what we talked about yeah
that's even crazier than I thought I
know man
so what's what's what's uh what's up
with you I like you do you ever like I
would like to close it down like with
people connect with your message is
there how do they best connect with you
do you ever do public talks I know you
go to Washington and you do protests and
all this activist stuff if somebody
wants to get on your wavelength like
what's the best way for them to do that
yeah well I guess I could give out my
email okay rich you might get a few
emails that's all I know
yeah well I am often I guess speaking at
different regenerative organic farming
conferences and cannabis we're launching
brother David's or I should be very
clear this has nothing to do that dr.
Bronner's my family but brother David's
regenerative cannabis flower line and be
hitting a lot of the cannabis trade
shows and that's to promote the small
family farmed outdoor correctly grown
medicine and it's a non-profit venture
totally all profits back to benefit you
know not because cannabis is fortune a
disease huge corporate indoor grows that
are dominating very energy and chemical
intensive so yeah I guess I'm out and
about a different yeah trade shows and
talking and but you can call up the
number on dr. Bronner's and you can
totally reach me by email I won't give
up my prayer really but yeah like
sometimes determined to get in touch oh
absolutely
no I will totally personally answer any
any sincere sweet note and and and
here's something I even if it's not
sweet if it's got good points all right
now so you could do that and as a final
kind of thing as a takeaway for people
that are listening to this I feel like
even if you're the most well-intentioned
and fairly adequately informed consumer
when
go to the grocery store the market
whatever you see all of these labels on
various products and it's confusing yeah
for the most intelligent among us like
what do these labels really mean it's
organic really mean what I think it
means what is cage-free me what does
grass-fed mean does that really mean
that these cows are having amazing lives
there's so many labels and I know for
myself I've lost confidence in in in the
idea that you know they actually live up
to the sort of you know promise and I
know in many ways they don't but you're
somebody who's really looked at this so
for somebody who is listening to this
like what are the labels they really
need to to pay attention to and what
should they know about like truth versus
fiction when it comes to these yeah well
you alluded to some of our litigation
and we did litigate against a lot of
what we called organic cheater brands
and a personal care space right yeah
because that it'd been so commodified
and watered-down yeah it was meaning
anywhere you could buy your way into it
essentially totally so the more I would
say meaningful certifications well first
and foremost is regenerative organic
certified it's not yet in the market
we're you know high that phase this year
but if you go to regen organic calm you
can kind of learn more about what the
standard is they have a list of products
there that adhere to that well
unfortunately Nonya at this point on the
market but you can get on the mailing
list and and then but what we did with
regen organic is take okay that what are
the top animal welfare pasture based
standards so that would be your gap for
so global animal partnership that's got
that ranking and Whole Foods so one two
three are pretty not super meaningful
but at Gap four that's when it gets
pretty meaningful so if you are going to
choosy meat or dairy look for gap four
or above and then animal welfare
approved is pretty much the highest
animal welfare a certification certified
humane pasture certified main and of
itself is a little not as strong but it
if it was a pasture claim with certified
humane certification that's pretty
meaningful on the fair labor side fair
for life
that's our certifier we're we believe
that's got a lot of walk you yeah and
fair for life and you know there's other
if that ensures fair wages adequate
working conditions
yeah gender equity and we actually pay
into a Fairtrade fund on materials and
labor that helps with community
development projects so Senate
sanitation like clean water wells or
school books for kids or defibrillator
for the hospital and so the so Fairtrade
certification is good and I mean the big
the big one here is fair trade USA and I
have my issues there but you know
there's a lot of really good products
and brands certified by them and then on
soil health
you know the obviously biodynamic in
Demeter is really good an organic USDA
Organic I mean you just got to know your
brand you know there's a big spectrum in
there and that's what we're hoping to do
with regenerative organic it's just
really
here's your single trustworthy seal that
on all these ones you can just trust and
what are the what are the barriers that
you're facing in terms of just adoption
well it's gonna be obviously consumer
education and breaking through all the
noise but we have partners like
Patagonia and I think we've got a good
list roster brands and I think
ultimately you got a kind of duty
research on a given brand but you know
like the guado I key is a big ally for
us and they do you know MOT say yeah and
you know and that's like do you do you
research them you're like wow this
couldn't be more awesome you know and
they're helping preserve rainforests and
supporting the guaca tribe and and that
certification could apply to cotton
garments and the like right yeah and so
Patagonia's got some pretty good stuff
you know they're similar in that they've
got you know certified cotton certified
rubber for their wetsuits
they're doing some really deep work into
their supply chains and I think that's
part of what is is knowing the brands
and you can see in our pilot like we do
have quite a key and new me and some
really good brands that are really going
that extra mile and I would say that the
certification is is it's good to look
for but ultimately need to do your
research on the brand and just figure
out you know really get a feel for them
right and like how committed are they
like is it okay they got like one or two
Fairtrade products but the rest of their
portfolio or product or brand portfolio
is like weak versus complete commitment
how do you know when you're looking at
these products and trying to evaluate
them when you're getting [ __ ] with
because I'm sure there's a lot of
marketing doublespeak and obfuscation
you know you try to make people think
that they're buying something that is oh
yeah man environmentally you know
comports with all the things you're
talking about but doesn't actually yeah
I mean reading ingredient acts is is key
and you know simple language you can
pronounce on a cosmetic obviously if you
can't pronounce it it's probably doesn't
belong on your skin and you know
obviously that will contradict whatever
green claims are being made if you're
like what's the seven syllable chemical
name I know it's like well yeah well I
think there's this sense that that if
you're buying something at the store
that it must be fine
well I'm friends with this woman Greg
Renfrew who has a company called
beautycounter she created this basically
this gigantic company cosmetics company
initially for women with beauty products
that are all like legitimately
all-natural without all the chemicals
because she was horrified to discover
that all these products that she thought
were natural quote-unquote natural
really weren't ya know boxes you just
think like well it must be okay I got it
nice that the Sephora or what
and you realize like yeah it's very far
from the case oh yeah there's no regular
bonuses on you is the consumer to really
be educated about these things
yeah it's buyer beware basically and
that but yeah I reading an ingredient
deck if you you know it should look like
a food like you're you're putting food
on your skin and if it reads different
than nice that's the biggest organ on
your body man yeah totally so what's
your favorite use of your product other
than as you know a typical soap well let
go of all the uses will firefighting for
people so what do I have to do to get
the foam truck to come to my house
oh no well next time we're round we'll
just come and do it yeah not throw a
really big party okay good cool man
thank you so much next time you have
some big initiative or some something
going on come back and talk to me man I
really enjoyed this yeah right on thank
you for having me been awesome I
appreciate I appreciate what you're
doing and I think it it's it's proof
that you can run a company with this
higher sense of purpose and this call to
service and do it in a financially not
just viable way but in a profitable way
this the the manner in which you have
grown this company to prominence is I
mean they should be teaching this at
Harvard Business School it's incredible
what you guys have built and you've done
it on principle with integrity and
that's to be commended and I hope more
companies out there can model their DNA
off you know what you guys have
established in created yeah right on
thank you and yeah and there are other
companies that have inspired us you know
like the quad keys of the world and yeah
and hopefully it's a virtuous cycle and
others will in turn be inspired yeah
Matt yes the all one vision brother BAM
unity of love right man peace peace BAM
[Music]